you know I thought I could wait to talk
about this but I really can't spoiler
warning spoiler warning spoiler warning
Game of Thrones last episode unbowed
unbent unbroken if you want my spoiler
free review it's already up I'm only
talking spoilers on this now when i did
that review I said that I couldn't talk
about what happened at the very end of
the episode that I didn't like because
it was completely getting into spoilers
and I'd probably have to say for my
overview of the season that i do once
all the episodes have aired what I've
come to realize as I digested it more
and I've watched the discussion around
it happen is if I wait until then to
talk about this then it's going to be
the only thing I talk about that entire
video I need to devote a video to just
this so I can get it out of my system
and what I'm talking about if you
haven't figured it out already is the
Ramsey Sansa marriage wedding night
thing now if you remember my review of
the episode I had a ton of problems with
this episode before that even happens so
the fact that I hate this episode is all
it was kind of a given even before this
happened but this was really the capper
on the thing and I said it already I
hate it I hate it for a lot of reasons
but it's not a knee-jerk reaction of oh
they raped a character poor I'm never
watching this show again really is it
serves absolutely no function and that's
why I hate it well it's the overriding
reason at any rate because that scene
the way it played out told us absolutely
nothing new about any of the characters
involved and nor did it move the story
forward in any way I mean this doesn't
tell us anything new about Ramsey we
know how bad Ramsay is and this is not
an extreme act for him for him this is
Tuesday not only doesn't tell us nothing
new about Sansa but it actually undoes a
moment that happened earlier which was
something i said i liked which is she
has that moment with that girl who
Ramsey was with earlier and says it kind
of puts her in her place and I really
liked that moment for Sansa but then
just shutting down and going to survival
mode again felt like it undid that
moment which was the first moment of
real character development for her in
years and then when it comes to Theon
reek whatever you want to call him all
it is doing is hammering the same point
that's been hammered home basically for
the last season and a half which is that
he's so broke any submissive he's so
broken he's submissive there's nothing
that his failing to do anything about
this tells us that he's failing to leave
what his sister came to rescue him last
season
I already told us so that's my
aggravation with the scene above all
else is that it serves no function and I
understand not absolutely everything
that ever gets shown has to have a plot
function and move the story for it it's
better if it does but you can have more
superfluous things but the thing is that
only works if what you're showing us
which doesn't move things forward it's
somehow viscerally satisfying a good
action scene can be viscerally
satisfying even though it's better if it
moves the plot forward a great bit of
dialogue between two characters can be
viscerally satisfying if it's really
witty or the interaction is funny but in
the case of this scene if you found that
seemed viscerally satisfying please take
a careful look at yourself going back to
what happened last season with Jamie and
Searcy now I didn't really like that
either but the reason I didn't like that
had largely to do with it felt like
didn't have a lot of impact on the story
or any impact at all really so I just
didn't see the point of it so it's kind
of the same issue here but I've got a
lot more problems with the ramsey Sansa
thing I kind of gave the Jamie Searcy
thing a little bit of a pass because I
felt like there was a failure of
execution I felt like what they were
going for was something more ambiguous
and they just messed up the execution
now what I cannot figure out is when
there was such a pretty sizable backlash
against that event last year why would
they go back to that same well again for
something that as I said serves no
function to the story or the characters
I mean you would think with the backlash
that this show got with the seriously
Jamie thing that they go okay if we ever
feel the need to go back to this sort of
action i guess the female character we
better be darn sure that it matters and
that it's important i suppose if i'm
going to give a sliver of benefit of the
doubt it's possible that this could pay
off in some way down the road but i just
don't see how that's gonna happen we
knew Sansa was in a crap situation
getting paired off with Ramsey we didn't
need to see this happen you know about
the only argument I've seen that I think
has any validity at all in terms of
showing this is that it was an
inevitability if they're gonna pair
Sansa off with Ramsey this is just gonna
be what happens and while I can buy that
in terms of the characters the situation
and whatnot that doesn't justify showing
us the six
then did scene of it I mean you could
have completely gotten the point of
cross just having Ramsey go into their
bedchamber give her like this evil look
which he has a ton of he's got to wear
repertoire of them and then we see the
door closed behind him go to black
that's it we know what's gonna happen we
know it's bad for Sansa you can imply it
some more specifics later on if you want
but we don't need to see it and because
it serves no function because it tells
us nothing about the characters and
doesn't move the plot forward it feels
cruel now this show can be cruel I mean
the death of Oberyn was incredibly cruel
but it served a purpose it was hammering
home the theme of that episode and it
was a capper on what Tyrion I talked
about before about there being no
justice with the guys smashing the
Beatles so it made a point stronger it
served a function we talk about other
cruel acts obviously the red wedding
completely rewrote the dynamic of the
world is also that had major plot
implications even going back to Ramsey
and his torture of fee on which I said
before went on too long and outstayed
its welcome for me but I at least I
understood why I was there because we
never seen Ramsay before this was our
introduction to this character so the
extent to which he was prepared to
torture Theon told us things about this
character so it served a purpose what
purpose does this scene in this episode
serve I can't find one and it doesn't
help that this feeds into just the
feeling of gender inequity and i'm not
talking about in the world i'm talking
about in the show and the way it's
presented i talked a couple of episodes
back about i think it was the third
episode there was casual female frontal
nudity but then in that same episode
they have three completely naked men and
the show goes out of its way to be sure
it does not show their frontal nudity at
all and just the inequity of the way
this is all being depicted is becoming
kind of glaring and I'm not even going
to make the leap that I know some people
already have made and are now making
that the show is inherently misogynistic
but I will say this the events of this
season so far make it harder to defend
the show against those accusations than
it used to be so I think that's it I
think I've gotten everything out of my
system now I don't want to ask you your
opinion on that scene or whatever
happened
because I've seen how those
conversations spiral out of control and
i'm just i'm done with it so instead let
me ask you this how do you want to see
ramsey died because regardless of your
feelings on this scene I think we can
all agree ramsey is a really bad guy who
deserves to die so how do you want to
see him get taken out whatever your
preferred method of ending Ramsey's life
is drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it until next time
this council is adjourned